hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and in this video i'm going to be
basically answering
your property investment questions i've
been investing in property now
for over 10 years 12 years now it's been
i've done hundreds of property deals
and so many people want to invest in
property want to make money in property
but they just don't quite know what to
do
what the next steps are so i'm going to
be answering your property investment
questions if you've got a question
please comment your question below also
do me a massive favor
smash the like button okay if you
appreciate my content
smash the like button also subscribe
turn the notification bell on
so you don't miss a future video and
let's see what we've got so some really
interesting questions
um harry heckles says hi samuel i would
like to know
are hmos still a good investment in 2020
my uncle says they are a thing of the
past as no one wants to share a bathroom
and so on also another question
is if i did buy hmo and wanted to put on
sweets in the rooms
do you have any idea on how much an
ensuite would cost to build in each
room so interesting question hmos are
100 not a thing of the past they are
booming right now people are queuing up
for rooms and if you don't believe me
go to spare room code at uk and just
have a quick look and you'll see people
queuing up for rooms advertising
themselves looking for a room you
literally type in
any city in the uk this is pretty much
worldwide by the way
if there's a booming city people are
wanting to rent rooms because
we're in a recession people haven't got
much money so they're looking for
affordable accommodation
now that being said on suites
where is a little bit of truth in what
your uncle said is people
are generally not loving the idea of
renting a room where they have to share
a bathroom that's true
in fact i've noticed over the last few
years people have
become more and more picky about what
kind of room they rent
so ensuite rooms are probably a good
idea uh this is
contrary to what i said four years ago
uh an ensuite will cost about two
thousand pounds to put into a room but
it depends on the type of ensuite the
size of room
the area but two thousand pounds is
about how much it will cost which is not
very much
at all so hope that helps great question
kenneth ward what is the tax situation
if equity is withdrawn by remortgaging
for reinvestment and or personal income
from a company
property and or personal property ken
ward the
tax situation on equity is that you
don't pay any tax
because you can't pay tax on debt
so it's tax free i hope that helps
joe wilson the wisest thing that should
be on every wise individual's list
is to invest in different stream of
income that don't depend on the
government to bring money
especially now the pan demick is hitting
economy pretty hard
not really a question more of a
statement but joe i would agree
i'd absolutely agree don't rely on the
government the government are trying to
become our parents the government are
trying to make it so that we all rely on
them right now
and i'm not buying it i want to be
self-sufficient
now whatever you whatever you do i mean
you could always say but if you have
gold the government could steal it
if you have properties they could take
it off but i mean with look within
reason
we want to be as self-sufficient as we
can i mean i've got friends that
literally have like farms and stuff and
grow their own crops because they're
scared that the government will
you know make it impossible for you to
eat and all kinds of stuff
and without going really deep into crazy
theories of
thinking that the government are trying
to kill everybody but for real the
government definitely have an agenda and
they're definitely trying to make people
reliant on them
and we are slipping in some areas from a
capita a capitalist
society to almost like a communist
society which i think is terrible
and i think it's really good and smart
to have income streams that are coming
in
and property in my opinion is one of the
best income streams there is because
everyone will always need somewhere to
live
so even though they've regulated
property quite heavily
we have a limited amount of land and
there's an overpopulation of people in
the shortage of houses
so if you own houses you're going to win
you're going to win especially if you
have a diverse portfolio and have
multiple strategies to your property
investment
income so i know i would agree with you
there joe okay
ellis evans by the way if you're
enjoying the video smash the like button
because there's not many people by the
way i just have to say this
that have become very successful in
property like i have
and actually keep doing content putting
videos out sharing their opinions
you know you do have a target on your
back when you make a lot of money and
then you talk about that
you do have a target on your back a
little bit from everybody from poor
people because they're jealous
from very rich people because they're
like hey don't tell everybody from the
government because your anti-system
so you know i do this because this is my
mission so please do me a massive
smash the like button drop a comment
below also subscribe evan ellis says
hi i have a question when i remortgage a
property
now worth more than the original value
does the money i get out of it
get put into my bank account or is it
held with accountants etc
it gets put into your bank and you don't
pay tax on it
it's debt so yeah like if the value goes
up
you should be able to borrow about 75
of the new value and then with that
money you're going to pay off the old
mortgage and then the difference
is yours to do what you want with but
invest
smartly and wisely it's smartly even a
word
i just made it up because it's although
you've although you've refinanced that
money you have a responsibility because
you're paying interest on that so if
you're paying three four percent
interest on that on that debt
you need to make sure that you make that
debt work for you
whereby it's producing 10 15 20 because
if it's not then you're down does that
make sense
so but the money goes to you it does not
sit with your accountants that would be
that would be ludicrous
alim hi samuel i'm 17 and i'm currently
doing a business course in college
i'm finding it boring and not as good i
know my real passion and i want
and what i want to do in my life is
property as i've been researching it now
for two to three years
respect i was wondering if i got a job
or apprenticeship at a state agent to
get experience
and knowledge from that side also get
contacts from there
could i also get you to be my mentor for
the next year
so i can learn and get all the knowledge
i need to start if so how much would
this cost and
what would i get with these payments
hope this makes sense so ellen first
thing i want to say is respect
i mean you're at college you're learning
business it's one of the tragedies
when you go down formal education is
even when you're learning strategies
like business
like real estate property investments
you're often learning from people that
haven't actually done it
and it's like this is the formal
credited
government-backed training but you're
learning business from somebody
who just read a few books and isn't
passionate about it so i'd probably be
bored as well if i was you
um your thinking is right you want to
get
work experience don't trade your time
for money but trade your time for
experience so work for free to get
experience
get a mentor you know you're thinking is
right i'd do that i think you probably
learn more
working find a small property investor
and say hey can i help out
can i just work for you for free i'll be
better and and and can i be your mentor
sure you know i mean we've got all
different types of mentoring packages
you can get training and mentoring and
coaching from me and my team for as
little as 95 pounds a month so
um probably a lot cheaper than going to
university to learn about business from
someone that just read a few books
you know good job respect all right next
love life 2020. loving the consistency
but please answer my question for once
all right here we go i'm going to answer
your question for once i'm torn i have a
small portfolio of buy to let properties
i'm in a position where i can buy a nice
flat in london to live in while taking
advantage of the stamp duty holiday and
the fact that i can get a much bigger
mortgage due to my current contract rate
which may change soon do i buy the flat
to live in
or in another buy to let property just
to add
if i'm to buy the london flat it'll be a
two bed so i'll have the option to rent
out one of the bedrooms
all right so firstly um great that
you've got a little portfolio already
if you do qualify for the whole
like schemes where you can get really
high mortgages lent to you because you
audio and problems if you can i'd say do
it
and buy an area whereby you predict
capital appreciation
if you're renting out a room and you've
got a lodger you won't pay tax on that
money
it makes sense i think it's smart i
think i think um
just make sure that you whatever you buy
if you're buying to
always always you said you're torn
because you've got two options
look at both options and work out what
the financial implications would be of
each option
if you buy a house to live in and rent
the room out what's the situation
financially where you at
if you buy a property and rent it out
how much you making on that and then
compare what's best
people say to me all the time samuel why
do you rent your house that you live in
because
because it's a mansion and if i bought
it i've done the two cases i thought
right if i was to buy that house
and and live in it what would be the
where would i be at financially how
would things been if i read
where i rent it and if i bought it i'd
be much worse off i'd have loads of
money tied up into it
i'd be better off so so you just gotta
look do a split test on each case by
case
um a choice that you have and then pull
the trigger and go for one
hope that helps all right edison i have
a question i have no savings
at all as i've been the only income of
our family for several years
respect hard worker you don't need money
to get started by the way you need
courage
knowledge network skills i am thinking
of getting a loan with the bank for 25
000 pounds to use as a deposit
can i use the bridging loan to complete
the purchase of a property so that i can
add value and remortgage it to pay off
the original 25 000 pounds
also can the bridging loan be higher
than the house price so i can use the
money to add value to it
so edison first year what i want to say
is i want to say all the things you're
talking about are possible
you can get a loan out and then get a
bridging
loan and buy a property and add value to
it using loans and bridges you can do
that
however couple things to make sure of
number one is make sure that the
property is a good property
okay if you're borrowing money and
you're super leveraged you need to make
sure that you're gonna be able to push
the value up to get some equity
secondly is you wanna make sure that
once you've completed the project you're
gonna be able to
have have the ability to get a new
mortgage on it because it might be that
you get a bridging loan
and you put a loan in and you push the
value but it's a great property but then
you can't refinance because you've not
got the credit behind you to do that so
check
with a broker a mortgage broker that you
are going to be able to refinance at the
end of the term
um and then the third thing i'll say is
um just always look at the risk and the
reward
and you know if you've got no money and
you're buying properties and you're
getting loans out and
all that stuff i did that so i can't
advise you against that
but it does come with risk and just make
sure that you always do a best case and
worst case unlikely case scenario
and make sure that the worst case isn't
going to isn't going to [ __ ] you
financially forever
um if if it goes bad if it doesn't work
out what are the repercussions of that
can you live with that
but you know i think i think you got the
potential to go real far
and um i hope i hope to get to know you
and i look forward to hearing your
success stories well done
all right ck hi sam you love the channel
i've been negotiating
a lease option agreement i advise the
seller to contact a solicitor
and the sister is advised to not go
through with the deal
what do i do now well for a start ck
um you should never have advised him to
speak to a slice then you should revise
them to speak to your solicitor
or not even your sister but a sister
that specializes in these option
agreements
you know you said you advised the said
to contact if you said to the seller oh
go speak to a solicitor
most solicitors don't know what lease
option agreements even are
so you need to you need this is all
about power team that would pain me so
bad if that happened to me
now you've got a good deal the seller's
up for a lease option agreement
perfect no money down house
scuppered by a bad solicitor that
doesn't know what they're talking about
hasn't got a clue
that could that little small mistake
could have cost you tens and tens of
thousands of pounds
you need to have a solicitor that you
know that specializes in these option
agreements and you need to say to the
seller
hey you know if we're going to go ahead
with this you know i'm happy to put you
in touch with a solicitor that i know
specializes in lease option agreements
specializes in property and if they go
oh i don't want to no no i've got my own
system i'd say listen
that's fine but in order for this deal
to go ahead is going to need to be done
with a solicitor that really understands
property and understands option
agreements
because solicitors often tend to have
two speeds one is slow and one is stop
and for me i'm a professional this is
what i do for a living
and this needs to happen it needs to
happen quickly so what kind
would you agree are you you know you
said you told me that you're in you have
a three-month time scale
yeah i have okay cool so i'll give you
the details of such a solicitor
give me a shout if i can give any
further help that's so important so
fundamental um
that you do that huh anyway
you can win this round now you can win
this around if you can
but learn from it okay next ay with
interest only mortgages what options
does one have once the contract is over
so once the agreement is over once the
mortgage term is over
let's say you've got a 20-year agreement
you're either going to pay off the
mortgage or you're going to refinance
again
hopefully the latter we don't i don't
like repayment mortgages because
repayment mortgages you're forced every
month to put a monthly amount aside
whereas if you have an interest only
mortgage hey if you want to put a
monthly amount aside you can
but you're not forced to so the world is
your oyster so that's where i always
recommend interest only payments
all right dad hi dad this is not my dad
this is just dad he says
read the purple rain question i don't
remember what the purple rain question
was now
but i think it's about company having a
limited company anyway do you need years
of accounts on your company in order to
get a mortgage
no or do you the director need a good
credit score
more likely yes i'm finding her
to understand what the lenders would be
lending against you without any account
or credit evidence thank you keeping the
videos coming
like shared over a year ago all right
dad um
if you're buying a property through a
company you're going to be a guarantor
to that company
you can set up a brand new company
called purple rain limited
okay and then you're going to be a
guarantor so as long as you can get a
mortgage
your company can get a mortgage but
buying through the company with you
being the guarantor there's tax
advantages
so i'd recommend you go speak to an
accountant i don't know if that helps
thanks for watching i appreciate you
being subscribed for over a year if
you're watching this and you're not
subscribed
subscribe okay next mammoth er
i began investing in crypto oh this is
like a spam
uh mr peter schiff i i get so much
spam on my youtube man honestly honestly
honestly
um and i apologize about that if you see
like spam messages coming on
trying to sell stuff or hate messages
you know some of yours are scrap it's
just like geez
we're here to just talk about property
folks
we're to just learn and grow together
geez go find someone else's channel to
troll on honestly serious
all right um elaine steele hi samuel if
you're using the brr model how do you
determine how high-end
finish to do for the refurb at what
point would you be spending too much on
the refurb to see any additional return
on investment in either rent or
refinance
aled great question so if i'm buying a
property as a brr
presumably i'm keeping that property at
the end because i'm buying it
refurbishing it
refinancing and renting it out so i want
it to be a good standard
i want to do a proper job you'll find
that you have better tenants your
tenants stay longer you're about to
charge a higher rent
so you want to do a high finish however
there's high finish like a good finish
and then there's high finish
now if you're living there yourself
you're going to be like oh i like that
bit more and you're going to use your
personal preferences to potentially
pay over the odds of stuff but it
doesn't matter because you're living
there
whereas if you're renting it out if it's
a property you're not going to be living
in
don't be getting like marble floors and
stuff you know
don't be spending like i would typically
spend on a kitchen obviously it depends
on where it is in the country
i'm not spending more than like three or
four thousand pounds on a new kitchen
i'm gonna get howden's kitchen
it's gonna look nice of course it also
depends on
the building see if you're renovating a
castle
for example you're going to get
obviously you're not going to get a 3
000 pound howden's kitchen
so it's all relative depending on
depending on
the type of building so it looks fitting
if it's a hundred thousand pound house
you're not going to spend 15 grand on a
kitchen because that would be crazy
you're going to spend two and a half
thousand pounds on the kitchen so
try if you c if you're buying the house
refurbishing with finance say
do it nice don't do everything on the
cheap but i would say
mid middle of the road middle of the
road but where it looks nice
you know you don't want you're spending
crazy money on carpets or cream carpets
you want to be getting the very basic
you know um
brown and dark brown light brown wrapped
around each other
that kind of carpet you'll get it for
like you'll pay i don't know you'll pay
a couple grand
to have the house carpeted that's the
kind of stuff but
it doesn't look bad looks alright but if
you spend a fortune on things like
carpets in a rented house
it's just gonna really pain you when the
tenants move out and they've damaged the
carpets and
so high end middle of the road decent
quality but
looks nice ikea ikea type vibe
not you know super i can't even think of
an example because i don't go to the
shops
like nice middle of the road hope that
helps
the real nihan honestly love your videos
very useful and informative i have a
quick question so who when
whenever i watch your brr strategy
videos you mention the money recycling
bit
which is after the refinance remortgage
however
how does the money which you have
invested in come out and
to your bank okay so basically
if you haven't done it i get that it's a
bit like how does this work what happens
and sometimes you just have to do it
you know but but trust me when you
refinance a property
it goes in your bank a lot of people are
asking this like does it go with your
accountant can you actually
use it um yes as long as there's not a
a restriction be honest when you're
refinancing be honest with your lender
and tell them look i'm refinancing to
reinvest into property so
you know as long as you're not trying to
commit mortgage fraud or pretend it's
for something else
but most lenders will be okay with that
that's very standard practice
so how how does it come out i don't
quite understand the question exactly
how does the money okay so how it works
is the lender
all right let's say i'm the lender and
i'm the i'm i'm the bank
and i'm saying to you your house is
worth 100 grand and you're saying to me
you want to refinance your house
i'm gonna go no problem firstly is there
any existing debt on the property if
there is
let's say there's a fifty thousand pound
mortgage already i'll go no problem
i'll lend you 75 grand on the property
however when it happens what you're
going to do is that 75 grand
is going to go to the solicitors it's
going to be done with the solicitors and
what's going to happen is
the 50 grand current debt is going to be
paid off and then you're going to get
the 75 grand but you're actually going
to be left with 25 grand if there's no
mortgage on the property or no existing
debt
i'll give you 75 grand i'll have a
charge on the property
a first charge so that you you can't
just sell the property
because there's a charge on there it's
still yours but when you sell that
property or if you try and refinance it
again
i've got to get my money back so you can
only have the money
as long as you have the property it's
very very straightforward
i get if you've not done it it's a bit
like how does this work i hope that was
helpful i hope this
helps you folks i really do and i
appreciate some of you are really
experienced some of you are not
experienced at all some of you are just
getting started
but you've just got to do it and then
and then see it happen but it's totally
uh real this is real now you can speak
to any decent
creative mortgage broker accountant
finance director
solicitor and they will vouch for what
i'm saying
i've done this hundreds of times
um i have bought a three-bedroom
house from auction and refurbished it
should i sell it now or wait
i'd probably without knowing where it is
i'd probably say sell it now of course
it's down to you
i can't tell you what to do but
properties are booming right now i'd
probably sell it now get your money in
okay big boss 619 how much tax would you
pay when collecting rent from your
tenants
on interest only payment so you're going
to pay tax on any profit that you make
so the key is to try and make as little
profit as possible by having a lot of
business expenses
i know this sounds a little bit backward
surely i want lots of profit you don't
i mean i made two million pound profit
last year and it actually pained me
because i ended up having to pay loads
of tax
so now i'm thinking how can i make no
profit and how you're going to do that
is by
you're going to think well what can i
actually claim as tax-deductible you
know for instance i run a training
company
if you invest in one of my training
companies that's tax deductible so it's
going to come off your profit you're
going to pay less tax
so how can you grow your business scale
your business invest in more things
and bring down your profit that sounds
backwards a little bit but
i'm just speaking from experience i'm
not a tax advisor but that's what i'm
doing now
another thing is um you know how much
tax would you pay
it really depends on how it's structured
so you don't pay any tax on the first
around about 11 000 pounds you profit
you pay no tax
and then after that you're going to
start paying more tax but you can do
things like
you should pay yourself a salary through
your company you can pay yourself up to
around about 40 000 pounds
and and you're going to pay nothing on
the first 11 and then from 11 to 40
you're gonna pay your seven and a half
percent
so what you could do is you can employ
your wife you can employ your kids
and then you can pay them salaries it's
gonna reduce the tax again so
listen i'm not a tax expert or a tax
advisor by any stretch of the
imagination
but i do kind of know what i'm doing
based on experience so please do speak
to a qualified tax accountant about this
and let them give you best bespoke
advice thanks so much
alessandro slavoo hi samuel how are you
i'm awesome buddy i appreciate you being
a subscriber my question might be stupid
but here it is no such thing as a stupid
question
without a buy to let mortgage we usually
can't rent the house out right
so how does this work in correlation
with lease option agreement how am i
able to rent out a house on the owner's
behalf if the house hasn't got a buy to
that scheme thanks in advance great
great question
so you're correct if you're renting out
any house
if there's a mortgage on the house that
restricts you
from renting that a house out i mean
very it would have to be a residential
mortgage
then what you're gonna have to do if
that is the case and if you're taking on
a property
on a lease option agreement is you have
to make sure that you get
consent from the lender to rent the
house out now in lease option agreement
terms
you can usually do this because lease
option agreements often are properties
with no mortgage on them they've been
inherited or whatever and
the seller just doesn't know what to do
with the house and doesn't need the
money now
or they're in negative equity and it
could be a buy to that or it could be a
residential property
if they're in negative equity and it's a
residential property you can say to the
lender
hey lender you lent out all this money
and now it's dropped we're in a really
precarious situation right now
please could we have consent to rent the
house out because we're in a financial
tricky situation they'll usually give it
to you so if they weren't
then you might have to move on to
another property but that's generally
the way we get around it hope that helps
buddy
great job rhys nibs do you have a new
office or a green screen i can't tell
both so we do have a new office so this
is my new home office
and um it's a great place i love it in
here
and most of my filming now if you sit
down winners wednesdays
you know we we come down here we film um
so it's a new office but we do also have
a green screen so this is not
this is not london behind me right now
this is it's okay
it's actually a blank wall so
um it would look pretty boring if we
didn't have
london behind us it would just be like
really dull it would just be a bland
wall and of course i want to make this
as
visually pleasing to the eye as possible
as well as content rich
so uh yeah but i hope you like the new
offices and if you become successful in
property maybe you'll get to sit down
and we can chat
and we can we can talk about your
journey in property and have you on
winners on a wednesday and you'll get to
see in person
thanks so much all right next patricia
kilty
hi samuel i remember seeing in one of
your videos that you had
made 100 people or so financially free
which is truly inspirational just
curious what is your current tally up to
great question so i've made way more
than 100 people financially free like
just on winners on a wednesday there's
more than 100 people um
you know what i am actually losing count
and last year
last year alone in 2019 100 like i
tallied 111
people financially free as a direct
result of my training
however i literally get people stopping
me in the street
saying oh my gosh i did your online
course
and and blah blah blah and now i'm
financially free i get that like
i literally cannot keep count of how
many people are financially free without
doing a tally of every person
on the planet and saying are you
financially free did it happen from
samuel's training
it's kind of impossible for me to keep a
tally so what i do instead
is i just um rather than counting i just
have
winners wednesdays every single week and
we've got queues with people so uh
yeah hope that helps a lot of people
though
all right last question mati bk says
keep up the great work i completed on my
first house a month ago
the house is a two bed over three floors
my plan is to rent out the two bedrooms
above
using the rent-a-room scheme already got
a friend who wants one
and create a sort of studio flat for
myself on the lower ground floor
do i need to follow any certain
regulations install fire doors etc
so matt um so for fire doors
if the property's not a hmo you don't
need fire doors
uh i don't think you're gonna need any
licenses or anything like this unless
it's in a selective licensing area i
don't know where it is
um but to have lodges in your property
you're just gonna put them on a
on a rental room contract uh you're not
gonna pay any tax because you're gonna
get bedroom relief tax for the first i
think it's up to seven thousand five
hundred pounds a year
uh which is which is amazing so i think
you're pretty okay
uh you might wanna get fire doors in
particularly um high risk rooms like if
maybe in the kitchen for a fire door but
fire doors are very cheap
anyway and they're good doors they're
good long lasting doors
so any doubts contact your local council
but great job
and honestly guys i really enjoy doing
these q a sunday videos
thanks for watching i hope you find this
content useful i want to give you
the best experience ever on my youtube
channel i want to give you the best
content ever
i can only do that by hearing your
questions your problems your challenges
and then i'll try and fix them best i
can so please do me a massive favor
comment your questions below and i will
then return the favor by answering as
many as i possibly can
don't forget to subscribe turn the
notification bell on and if you enjoy my
videos
smash the like button and share with a
friend thanks for watching i'll see you
next time
[Music]